For much of the early history of photography
smiling in photographs was almost unheard
of for various reasons.
(See: When Did People Start Smiling in Photographs?)
Despite this, a photo of a Chinese man, dubbed
by the masses on the internet, “the happiest
man in China”, occasionally makes the rounds
purporting to be of a 19th century Chinese
man who unabashedly displays a wide, toothy
grin for the camera.
This, in addition to the man’s remarkably
photogenic appearance and near flawless smile,
has naturally led many to dismiss the photo
as fake- seemingly just a picture someone
recently took and digitally touched up to
appear like a photo from the 19th or early
20th centuries.
So is the “happiest man in China” photo
a fake and who is the smiling man?
As for the latter question, very unfortunately,
nobody knows.
We do, however, know the photo is genuine
and how it survived through today.
Officially titled “Eating rice, China”
(and originally captioned “Chinaman eating
rice”), the picture is one of originally
143 photographs (105 of which can be seen
here) collated by famed sinologist (more or
less “expert on China”) Berthold Laufer
who, in 1904, returned from a landmark three
year trip to the Orient with about 7,500 objects
intended to showcase the day to day life of
the average Chinese individual at the time.
As to this little adventure, Laufer, who did
not take a camera with him, was sent on behalf
of the American Museum of Natural History.
According to a 1902 letter written by anthropologist
Franz Boas, the main objective of the expedition
was to
bring together collections which illustrate
the popular customs and beliefs of the Chinese,
their industries, and their mode of life…
to bring out the complexity of Chinese culture,
the high degree of technical development achieved
by the people, the love of art, which pervades
their whole life, and the strong social ties
that bind the people together.
In bringing together collections bearing upon
these points of view, we desire to illustrate
the needs of the Chinese and the products
of their industries.
These will demonstrate the commercial and
social possibilities of more extended intercourse.
We also wish to imbue the public with greater
respect for the achievements of Chinese civilization.
Our object has not been to bring together
a collection of Chinese works of art- this
matter belongs more properly to the scope
of an art museum- but to emphasize the general
characteristics of Chinese culture…
The ulterior motive here, as alluded to in
the letter, was to explore the potential for
various business dealings with China, which
is how the museum and Laufer got banker Jacob
H. Schiff to fund the expedition; Schiff was
partnered with various businessmen including
railroad magnate E.H.
Harriman, former senator Calvin Brice, and
J.P. Morgan, all of whom were looking to expand
their business dealings into China.
Over the course of his travels, Laufer set
about collecting literally thousands of random
objects he felt were representatives of Chinese
culture and life, resulting in, as the museum
itself notes:
an extensive collection of representative
objects used in daily life, agriculture, folk
religion, medicine, and in the practice of
such crafts as printing, bookbinding, carpentry,
enamelware, ceramics, and laquerware.
Laufer also collected numerous musical instruments,
costumes, articles of clothing as well as
wax cylinder recordings of traditional Chinese
songs and plays.
Due to his interest in Chinese theatre, he
also ended up returning to the States with
the “most extensive collection of Chinese
puppets in North America including shadow
puppets, rod puppets, and glove puppets in
several regional styles”.
It’s not clear where Laufer acquired many
of the objects he collected, though in most
cases it appears he simply bought the items
either from antique dealers or the market
stalls found in the hutongs of major cities.
Although Laufer would claim in a letter home
that during his journey “there is no path
I do not walkover, no cave I do not enter”,
in reality he spent the majority of his time
in Peking and despite repeated request from
the Museum to interview actual Chinese people,
tended to gather his quotes from books.
This all brings us back to the photos he acquired
during his trip.
As he didn’t take a camera with him, it
is thought that Laufer himself didn’t take
any of the pictures he sent back to the museum.
The approximately 143 photographs he did collect
were largely purchased from unknown sources,
with the American Museum of Natural History
admitting that many of the photos Laufer found
“are known to be widely-distributed images
available for purchase at the time”.
Among these images depicting various facets
of Chinese life and culture is the aforementioned
unknown happy man eating rice.
According to the museum, the photo is, as
previously noted, a genuine picture from the
turn of the century and in their opinion was
likely taken between 1901 and 1904- the dates
of Laufer’s trip.
While it’s sometimes claimed that the man
was having his photo taken at Laufer’s request
in order to demonstrate the eating of this
staple of the Chinese diet, there is no documented
evidence that this is actually the case.
Further rumors that the man struck his happy
pose as he had no knowledge of etiquette in
photography at the time can likewise not be
substantiated by any documented evidence we
can find.
All we can definitively say based on available
evidence is that the photo isn’t part of
some elaborate internet ruse, it was taken
sometime around the end of the 19th or early
20th centuries, and it was collected by Laufer
and sent back to the American Museum of Natural
History during his 1901-1904 expedition.